good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the corona virus is now
in every American state that's killed
more than a hundred people here so far
that number of course will rise in Italy
the virus killed almost 500 people today
nobody is invulnerable to it just an
hour ago congressman Mario Diaz Florida
Florida became the first federal
lawmaker confirmed to have the virus
will be covering every aspect of this
pandemic this hour the economic effect
of it the effect on society the role of
China in all of this which is
significant well seven interview with
the person who's recovering from the
virus right now what does it feel like
you'll hear that but before that as we
have every night we want to open with a
big picture look at the current state of
Crona virus and who better than dr.
Anthony Fauci who's director of the
National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases dr. factory joins us
tonight dr. thanks so much for coming on
so the the federal government the
administration has spent an enormous
amount of money responding and looks
like they're pouring all their energy
and all their efforts into protecting
the country from this as of now is it
working do you think well I mean I'm
certain it's it's having an impact it's
not able to be measured precisely
because you have two things going on at
the same time Tucker you have an
escalation of the infections and you
have all of the things that we've been
talking about and doing over the past
few days that is aimed at blunting that
but when you have these two dynamic
things going on at the same time you
can't quantitatively say how much it's
having an effect but for absolutely
certain it's having an effect when you
do the kind of mitigation approaches
that are being done right now and all
the other effort that's been going in
right now
certainly it's having an effect however
you're gonna see tomorrow as you just
mentioned now there will be more cases
and they will continue to go up
that doesn't mean yes what we're doing
is not having an important effect where
are we can you estimate in the
development of this when you're saying
the development you mean in the
evolution of the outbreak Tucker's that
would just mean that's exactly right in
the evolution of the outbreak of Crona
virus in the u.s. yeah it's still in the
escalation phase there's no doubt about
it because you look at the numbers you
take a look it's uneven
there are certain parts of the country
that got hit early and had community
spread like in Washington State New York
right now is having a particularly
difficult problem that's the way you're
gonna see it over the next few weeks
you're gonna see not a homogeneous
evolution of it it's gonna be this way
throughout the country what do you think
the real number is is is it knowable or
guessable is it worth guessing of
infected patients you know it's not
worth guessing Tucker certainly as you
know when you have an evolution of an
outbreak and historically this is true
for every outbreak particularly ones of
diseases that we never had experience
with before there are certainly more
people out there probably many more
people who are infected who have not yet
come to our attention that's one of the
reasons why the major expansion of a
high throughput testing is gonna give us
a better idea of that but I think it's
folly to try to put a number on it when
you have something that's in motion and
dynamically moving that sounds right I
want to ask you a specific question that
arose today so the World Health
Organization is suggesting that people
not use ibuprofen
so that would be brand name Advil and
French researchers are saying the same
suggesting it might exacerbate the
disease its progression to the lungs is
that is that a good guidance do you
think do you do you think that's true
well you know there is no real
scientific data Tucker that tells you
that that is a fact or evidence based I
think what they're referring to is they
want to be the better part of really
being cautious because there is a
syndrome that's associated with the use
of aspirin in children with influenza
that gives them a neurological syndrome
call Reye's syndrome and I believe what
they're thinking since there's a
relationship obviously between
nonsteroidals and aspirin that maybe
there'll be some harm but there's no
real study that definitively proves that
but they're just trying to be very
cautious would you take it
what would I take it I mean I I when I
get a fever or an ache I take tylenol
but I've been doing that all my life
that's good enough for me
doctor fetching great to see tonight
thank you for that